You come from above
like him.
He will burn the world to find you.
Who? The conqueror.
Kang the Conqueror
is the new iconic villain in the MCU.
We knew we wanted to go to places
that we'd never been at,
pitting Ant-Man against a major villain
felt perfect.
Audiences have seen their version
of this character in the series.
Loki.
This is why
in our film, he's very different.
Kang is in infinite number
of different personas,
and you need an actor
to be able to pull that off.
And that is Jonathan Majors.
I can rewrite existence
and shattered timelines in this film.
This is really a side of him
we haven't seen.
This is his badass self.
I will take my revenge
from those who banished me
and I will burn them out of time.
I think the
film is ultimately about how time plays
within our relationship.
Love, Friendship.
Legacy.
Ant-Man versus Kang.
This is it.
People are going to lose their mind.
Yeah.
If you leave Ant-Man
the Conqueror,
he will burn the world
to find you on February 17.
If you want to stop.
What's coming, Gotta hurry. Ant-Man.
I don't care who this guy is.
This is my fight.
I'm coming for you.
You think you can beat me?
I am Kang.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie Marvel.
Dropped a whole bunch of new Ant-Man
and the Wasp.
Quantumania footage
is a bunch of Easter eggs and references.
We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
we're doing a giveaway for IMAX
tickets for the movie
because it's coming out so soon.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just let me know what you want them
to do with all the different Kang
variants in future Marvel movies.
There's so much footage to talk about that
they revealed during this.
But one of the coolest things is basically
Kang explaining what's going
on, like what his plan is after
he escapes the quantum realm.
He basically says he's going to start
the Kang Multiverse War again in earnest
if it's not already. Still going
on. Kevin Buggin.
The other Marvel producers
are a little bit confusing
because they all say
slightly different things
about the different Kang's back stories,
like he who remains Kang in the new Kang
variant that pops up after he dies.
But during this footage, when he talks
about being pissed off and going
after the people that kicked him out,
what he's referring to
is the Council of Kangs.
He's basically making it sound like
he started the Kang Multiverse War
because this is meant to be the worst
variant of Kang that we met so far
in the one that started the Kang
Multiverse War in the first place.
When he talks about burning the others
out of existence,
he's talking about burning the other
Kang's timelines down,
basically erasing all of the other Kang's,
which is the Kang Multiverse War.
And it sounds like the reason
why he was kicked out
is because they just thought
that he was too crazy when he remains.
Version of Kang
was talking to Loki and Sylvie
explaining the whole backstory
with the Kang Multiverse War in why
he did everything that he did with Elias,
the TVA in the sacred timeline.
He explained the full backstory
of all the different Kang variants.
Now they all have slightly
different backstories
because there's subtle variations
between the different variants,
but they're all very similar
in certain ways.
They all start out on a version of Earth
in the 30th century as Nathaniel Richards,
and then slowly over time
become the different versions of Kang.
Now, these are all references
to the comic book
versions of the character
who go by a lot of different names
and will meet those different variants,
like the Rama version of Kang
the Scarlet Centurion.
Obviously, this is the Kang
the Conqueror version of the character.
He who remains was meant to be
the immortal version of the character,
will probably eventually meet an Iron Lad
Kid Kang version of the character
when he's talking about their backstory.
After they discover the other universes,
they formed the Council of Kangs,
and all the different variants
are working together in concert
to the betterment of each other universes,
sharing technology.
And it's meant to be
this very positive thing.
Like, yeah,
it was great for a while until Daud Kang
the Conqueror comes along and sees only
other universes are places to conquer.
And that's where we pick up
with this variant of Kang the Conqueror.
The way that Marvel and Kevin
5G talked about it,
they say that Sylvie's started
the Kang Multiverse War 2.0
because when she killed he who remains
that allowed the timeline to reboot
and basically everything played out again,
but in a slightly different way.
So the Kang Multiverse
war played out again.
Marvel hasn't been totally clear as to
whether or not this Kang the Conqueror
variant is from the new timeline,
like the rebooted timeline,
or if he was from the original Kang
Multiverse or and just got trapped
in the quantum realm and was protected
from what he who remains did.
Getting rid
of all the other Kang variants with a lie.
The way that Jonathan Majors talks
in this clip, he makes it sound like he's
from the original timeline.
The very first timeline
when the first Multiverse war played out.
If it wasn't clear the way the quantum
realm works, it's protected from changes
in the timeline and from things
like the SNAP, for instance.
So when he remains went along
with Alliance
eating all these other timelines
and creating the sacred time,
like the one timeline
that we've been seeing across Marvel,
Phase one, phase two and Phase three
until Sylvie killed him,
It sounds like what happened
is this Kang the Conqueror variant
had been part of the Council of Kangs.
Then they kicked him out
because he was too crazy
and he swore revenge on them
that he started the Kang Multiverse War
and during that he crashed
in the quantum realm.
And as the Kang Multiverse War
played out that first time, he who remains
wound up winning by using a lie
in creating the sacred timeline.
But all that time, this Kang
the Conqueror variant
was trapped in the quantum realm,
basically on the sidelines.
And while that was happening
when he crashed the first time, he met
Janet Van Dyne,
then tricked her into helping him
try to escape until she figured out
what was going on,
then basically disabled his time ship
by taking out this orbit, hiding it.
That's why he needs Scott Lang to, one,
find it and then use his Pym particles
to put it back in his special
time ship here.
I think what's going on
is this giant spinning device
that looks kind of like Chung.
She's ten rings of power
because of the symbols on it.
There's also kind of look like celestial
symbols, too, which would make sense.
KANG Using very advanced technology,
the Celestials have the most advanced
technology in the universe.
It sounds like what Janet Van Di did
is when she disabled his ship,
she took that small power device,
used her Pym particles to make it big
so that he couldn't use it anymore.
There's still a lot of questions there.
Like if Kang so advanced, why couldn't he
figure out how to recreate Pym particles?
I'm assuming that they explained
that during the course of the movie.
But the big idea is that during the movie,
Ant-Man is trying to sacrifice himself.
Like they have all these clips
where he says,
You thought that you could win, where he's
taunting Ant-Man because there's no way
that Amy could beat him in a knockdown,
drag out fight.
Like,
even if they didn't have their technology.
Kang is just so much bigger.
Like Jonathan Majors is swole
compared to Ant-Man, and he does have
all his technology and Kang's technology
is so much more advanced than Ant-Man's.
One of the big things about the Ant-Man
character is that he's
meant to be a thief and surprise
people like the whole close up
magic joke with Jimmy Woo.
Jimmy Woo is also in the movie.
He's coming back.
I'll explain him in a second.
Ant-Man is one of those characters
that nobody would suspect and winds up
surprising you with really huge W's.
He helped the Avengers use the quantum
realm to basically bring everyone back,
and he's riding that celebrity
during the movie,
selling books,
selling merchandise, getting rich.
So the kind of going with that vibe
during the movie
with Ant-Man versus Kang, like there's
no way he's going to win an actual fight,
so he's going to surprise them
with some big twist in the big twist.
It sounds like the way that Ant-Man
is talking about it,
he's going to try and sacrifice his life
to prevent him from escaping.
Even though we know Ant-Man
will eventually come back for either
Avengers five, Cane Dynasty or Avengers
six Secret words like He will come back
at some point, meaning that
he will not die during this movie.
They're probably going to wind up
killing a bunch of versions of Ant-Man
during this because you see
many variants like an Army of Ant-Man,
Like there's an army of ants.
That's the whole joke
we're talking about time travel variance.
You have armies of ants
now you have an army of ant men,
a bunch of different variants.
They'll probably kill a bunch of those off
like you see one die during the trailer,
but the 616 version of Ant-Man
will survive.
I think that'll be one of the big teasers
at the end of the movie
as they built into Young Avengers
with Cassie laying
like she'll escape at the end of the movie
and will feel responsible
for what happened to her father
and will try to rescue him.
But also as part of that, if Ant-Man
isn't successful in sacrificing himself,
it also means that Kang has to escape
because he's going to be the version
of Kang that they faced during Avengers
five Qing Dynasty.
That's why they keep using
the term Dynasty in all the trailers.
That's the other big thing
Kevin Feige is hyping up here.
Like you've never seen a villain
like Kang the Conqueror we saw he remains,
but he's nothing
compared to this variant of Kang.
This one is meant to be way worse.
The worst variants of Kang.
I'm just really excited
to see Jonathan Majors tear it up
as all these different Kang variants
like the one in ant man and the wasp
Quantumania looks cool,
but I can't wait to see
all the different variants of Kang
during Loki Season two.
There's a bunch of new characters
that get dialog during the trailers too.
This character is named Jin Tah
when she talks about you being from above.
Just like him
talking about Kang the Conqueror.
Because Kang got stuck in the quantum
realm in the first place.
Her name is Jin Tora.
She's the leader of the Freedom Fighters,
a group of people in the quantum realm
who lived there before Kang was stranded
there in before he conquered it,
after which they gave him
his full comic book name.
He was already calling himself
Kang when he was stranded there.
But they named him the Conqueror,
as they do during the clip,
and thus he became Kang the Conqueror.
The freedom fighters are basically
the characters that they encounter
when they first land in the quantum realm.
One of the other big ones is Kaz, played
by William Jackson Harper.
You see them Storm Kang's chronopolis city
with a bunch of their army
in a bunch of ants as well.
Wouldn't be an ant man movie
if they don't use a bunch of giant ants,
even though he's not in the trailers.
Like I said, Randall Park, though
Jimmy Woo is supposed to be in the movie,
he's listed in the IMDB credits,
but that be in the normal world,
like the early part of the film,
when you're seeing all the good things
that have happened to Scott Lang
since the events of Avengers Endgame.
He's from the San Francisco area.
The reason why he was in one division was
because he was on a missing persons case
that was related to
what was happening in San Francisco.
So he just come to the other side
of the United States for that.
During the last Ant-Man and the Wasp
movie, he'd been under house arrest
and that was set and close
to the events of Avengers Infinity War.
But that was before the snap and when
the blip happened in Avengers Endgame.
So before all that, Jimmy Woo
didn't really like Scott Lang that much.
He was kind of fascinated by him,
but he's still pretty wary of him.
Since then, though,
since Avengers Endgame in The Blip,
Ant-Man is being lauded as a hero.
He's using this popularity is an Avenger,
defeating Thanos in Avengers Endgame,
bringing everyone back to sell
a ton of merch and make a bunch of money.
They'll probably have a bunch of jokes
about that.
Like they even had a clip
where they joke about Scott Lang listening
to his own book on audiotape,
and he's reading it so like he's
listening to himself talk
about his adventures with The Avengers.
So they might have some joke about Jimmy
Woo reading Scott Lang's book.
The original joke in the last
movie was a Jimmy.
We were so fascinated by him being able
to do close up Magic that he started
the online school training.
They even released a funny promo
for the Magic School
that Jimmy was studying,
and they confirmed
that the character did not get snapped.
So he spent the five year time
jump continuing to study close up magic.
And that's why during one division, he's
so much better at impressing
Monica Rambeau.
Maybe at some point outside chance
he'll have a scene with Doctor Strange
where he tries
to impress them with his close up magic
and they just play it for comedy.
There's a whole bunch of other footage
here.
They dropped a bunch of other clips too.
I'll try to do videos for that stuff later
this week.
Like Kang talking about Thor
and the other Avengers characters.
You have to remember that
he faced many versions of the Avengers
before in different universes
and killed them
all, which is why he's standing here
today.
That's how he got all of his scars
on his face, fighting the other Avengers
from different universes,
killing them and fighting the other
variants of Kang and killing them as well.
On the new giveaway
winner, My next big Marvel video.
There's a bunch of Super Bowl trailers
coming this week.
I will do videos for everything.
Be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that
brand New Black Panther
Wakanda Forever Deleted scene
and click here for my Invincible Season
two trailer video and learn about Jeffrey
Dean Morgan coming
as a really big character.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.